طقوس الاحتفاليه تقليديه تحيي ذكرى قصه
الانتقام الاكثر شهره في التاريخ الياباني
وهي حادثه اكم اذ يحكى ان قائد الساموراي
لمقاطعه اكو في بدايه القرن الثامن عشر
تشاجر مع احد رؤسائه ويدعكره بسبب اهالته
له وحكم على قائد الساموراي بالاعدام
بينما لم يتلقى كره يعقوبه بعد عامين من
موت سيدهم ظلما اجتمع سبعه 47 محاربا من
اتباعه
في مقر اقامته ثم صاروا براسه الى معبد
سندكودي لتقديمه الى قبر قائده
وهي طريقه خاصه باعدام الساموراي
نسيت ان اليوم هو يوم انتقام الساموراي
السبعه والاربعين وقد ذكرني به الموكب نحن
نحب القصه ونعرفها من خلال الادب والافلام
والدرمه التلفزيونيه
يمشي يوما واحدا وهم يرتدون الازياء
التقليديه للساموراي تعبيرا عن الامتنان
لهذه الحقبه التاريخيه الذهبيه ولتذكير
بقصه المحاربين
[موسيقى]
اشكرك انني واحد من محارب الساموراي
الحقيقيين التابعين انا ارتدي هذا الجزء
المصنوع من المعدن لحمايه الراس حتى لو تم
الهجوم بالسيف
والاربعون لرد اعتبار قائدهم وبعد شهر
انتحروا بشكل جماعي ورغم ان النهايه حزينه
اقتراب موكب من محطته الاخيره في معبد سنغ
كودي يستدعي كل عام تدخل الشرطه في تنظيم
السير مع احتشادي العامه وعقد مهرجان خاص
باسمهم يرقدوا هنا
47 ساموراي مع قائدهم حيث شهد المعبد
الوقائع التاريخيه الاصليه التي سردتها
ايضا افلام سينمائيه ويزور قبورهم العامه
تقديرا واعجابا الى يومنا هذا